you
[Applause]
so containment is this idea that you can
focus your effort on control very much
on the cases in their contacts so you're
not causing disruption to the wider
population you have a case that comes in
you isolate them you work out who
they've come into contact with who's
potentially these got opportunities for
exposure and then you can follow up
those people maybe quarantine them to
make sure that no further transmission
happens so it's a very kind of focused
targeted method and for SARS it worked
remarkably well but I think for this
infection because some cases are going
missed and being undetected you've
really got to be capturing a large chunk
of people at risk if a few sit through
the net potentially going to get an
outbreak
in that respect it would be about
massive changes in our social
interactions and so that would require
of the opportunities that could spread
the virus so these kind of close
contacts everybody in the population on
average would be needing to reduce those
interactions potentially by two-thirds
to bring it under control and so that
that might be through through working
from home from changing you know
lifestyle and kind of where you go and
in crowded places and dinners and then
of course these measures things like
school closures and other things that
they just attempt to reduce the social
mixing of a population
you shake it's whose hand that person
goes on to shake and I think we need to
think about these these second degree
steps that you might think you have low
risk and you're in a younger group but
you're often gonna be a very short step
away from someone who's gonna get hit
very hard by this and I think we really
need to to be socially minded and think
this could be quite dramatic in terms of
change of behavior but it needs to be to
reduce the impact that we're potentially
facing
I think it's hard to pin down exactly
but I think one thing to bear in mind is
that there's not so much evidence that
this is a kind of error so and it goes
really far that it is reasonably short
distances so yeah I don't think it's the
case that you're sitting at a few meters
away from someone in the vise or somehow
gonna get across I think it's really
it's as close-knit interactions is why
we're seeing so many transmission events
occurring things like meals and and
really have tight-knit groups because if
you imagine that's where you can get
virus out and on two surfaces and on two
hands and on two faces and it's really
kind of situations like that we've got
to think more about
I think that's what people are trying to
piece together first in terms of what
works it's only really in the last sort
of a few weeks we've got a sense that
this thing can be controllable with this
extent of interventions but of course
not all countries can do what China have
done some of these measures incur a huge
sort of social economic psychological
burden on populations and of course
there's the time limit even I've had
them for six weeks it's tough to
maintain that so we need to to think of
these trade-offs of actually of all the
things we can ask people to do what's
going to have the most impact on
actually reducing the burden
[Music]